this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much for this
introduction and for giving me
an opportunity to talk about the
research project that i've been doing
for the last
year with some with collaborators in
microbiology and cti
before i talk about the actual project i
want to give you a little bit of
there we go a little bit of background
about active learning initiatives
so as don mentioned i'm an active
learning postdoc
there are a group of us at cornell
it was started in 2013 to improve
undergraduate classes in physics and
biology some of the big electric
classes and has now expanded
across uh various departments in the
fall of 2020 we have 18 fellows across
18 departments
we have everything from mechanical
engineering to classics
to plants the main goal is to bring
active learning to
different classes to assist faculty with
doing that
so really we're we're here for the
faculty at sips
there are two of us me and neil's
proctor our main focus is on the 10 core
courses for the plant science major
that being said if there are any faculty
who have any questions about active
learning
especially now that we've transitioned
to this hybrid model with an online
component
please contact me i'd be more than happy
to sit down or resume and talk about
your labs your course
really anything you might need help with
so this is a picture of our fellows
last spring we all went online and so it
felt like we were having this online
zoom war council
as we were all trying to figure out how
to use zoom there's been many hours
spent
testing breakout rooms and various
features and we're continuing to do so
and so we are all a resource here for
the faculty so if you have any any
questions
please let us know so i just want to
talk a little bit about the role
like i said the role is mainly support
and it's really as a jack of all trades
i have written exam questions
i've designed activities i'm sure if you
ask bill you
um they can give you plenty of more
examples of that
but really we're just we're here as
support
one of the one of the thoughts last year
that i had with some of my collaborators
was
how do we get the students to study
better
we all had students in our classes
studying for the exams
and they often just read the book they
look over their notes
and then when we ask them application
questions or questions at a higher level
of bloom taxonomy they flounder
and so this this idea of metacognition
of thinking about how you're studying
kind of led us to this project we
thought that one of the best ways for
the students to
learn is to teach the material
any of us who've gotten in front of a
classroom know that if you can teach the
material
that means you actually understand it
sandra mcguire's quote i started the
presentation with
has talked about a method of explaining
the material to your goldfish
or anything you know your cat your dog
anyone who's willing to listen to you
usually your pets are probably the more
captive audience
and so we didn't want to put the
students make the students get in front
of the classroom and so we decided to do
this video project
one of my collaborators for microbiology
kathleen heffern has done this video
project
in her classes when she was in toronto
and so that was how this project came
along
and the reason we want to use videos is
that students already know how to use
videos if you assign a student on topic
mitosis meiosis anything one of the and
they don't understand that one of the
first thing they will do is they will go
on youtube and google it
and look up the videos from the khan
academy crash course in biology
really anything they could find and so
they're already used to using that
technology to
learn the material they also know how to
make the videos
they're all from all almost all of them
either have a smartphone or a laptop
with a webcam
especially now with everything moving to
zoom
so they're familiar with it
and this was a way for them to engage
with the material
in a different way than just okay here's
the material
here's a quiz we're moving it on if they
have to make a video they have to break
this down
in a way that makes sense for the uh to
them but also to their audience
and so that way they get to engage with
the material
break it down and i understand it better
so as i mentioned before we want to
encourage the students to study by
teaching the material to their peers and
instead of having to make
have them come up in the classroom we
have them make a video
and this also allows them to use their
individual creativity
often times exams quiz get made
with this kind of
it's the same for everybody the students
are not allowed to use their
individuality their creativity and this
will allow them to do that
and we also want them to understand the
complex topics
the topics that i'm going to be talking
about in this presentation
is photosynthesis and tropisms
you can use anything um any other topic
that the students might struggle with
i was very lucky that i worked with uh
dr miller dr silva
for their courses and they were very
interested
and about the video project and let me
do another classroom
so in the fall of last year i worked in
plci 1101
it's the first class that most students
who come into cornell
with the wannabe plan science majors
take it was mostly freshmen with a few
transfer students
and a few students who were not planned
science majors they're about 65 students
the class was a mix of explaining to the
students what a plant is
what is some of the history of it and
also
some of the structures of the plants
the class also had about half the class
were guest lecturers
from across sips faculty members talking
about the research
talking about how you can use plants in
different careers different applications
in the spring i worked with dr tom silva
which was the second class in the
sequence it was a again a mix of second
semester freshmen sophomores and we had
a
a good number of students from
viticulture and knowledge and
agriculture science
the class there focused even more in
depth on plant structure and function
students learned about xylem and phloem
went into more depth about
photosynthesis and what makes this class
unique is that halfway through
we also went online and so the video
assignment the students
which you will see the students done
while
at their home in quarantine with
whatever
materials they have around uh their
house
but it's a research project so the way
to set this up is first
all students got the lecture about the
material so in
those class he gave the lecture about
photosynthesis
uh i administered an in-person quiz
with questions that were both there's a
mix of multiple choice
true false and short answer with every
question on that quiz that could have
been answered just from the lecture that
they had just heard
for 1420 for the spring
the class at that point has gone online
already
so dr silver has recorded videos about
the topic
the students watch that and then we
administered a time
canvas quiz and the students were told
that it was going to be closed book
and there we had a more uh the slant was
more short answer questions
so hopefully harder questions the
interesting part about that
class is that there was no incentive for
the students to study the material
anymore
once they've watched the video and taken
both this quiz and the quiz following
the videos there was no final exam
that was just project based and so any
studying
any gain and understanding they might
have done came straight from the video
assignment
so after they've done the quiz we
divided them up
into two groups topic a and b
so for photosynthesis it was light and
dark reactions
for tropisms it was photo phototropism
and gravitropism
and we gave the prompt they made the
video about their subject
and then once they submitted that
usually we gave them about a week to do
it
they took the same post quiz again
administered in the same way
as it was done for the pre-quiz
i wrote the prompts i wrote them to be
very specific
because i want to make sure that the
students cover
what the information that is basically
that was going to be on the quiz and
also so it was easier to grade
so this is the photosynthesis prompt
they were asked to submit a three to
five minute video
where they get to explain either light
or dark reaction and so they need to
know the purpose of light reactions
where they occur how atp and oxygen
produce and what are the products
with the dark reactions talk about
the purpose again where does it happen
how rubisco's involved and the
difference between c3 c4 and cam plans
the difference between c3 c4 and cam
plans was a short answer question
on the quiz that was that they struggled
with the most
so what i'm going to show you uh
hopefully i don't play and
don can point tell me if the sound
doesn't play is a
compilation of the videos of some of the
videos that i
the students made for the photosynthesis
video
um so just in terms of grading
i graded all of these i had a rubric for
the
tropism one the tas graded that but
really you don't even have to grade them
because the gain is the fact that
students made them so if you have a very
large class
you can just say it can be completion
only or you can share them with the
students so they can use it as a study
material
all right let's hope this works
down give me a thumbs up once you hear
actual sound all right
so here we're going to learn about the
light reactions
now there's a lot going on over here so
let's break it down
so what goes into the light reactions
well there's really three
sort of things there's water here
there's photons light energy
and there's various plant structures and
plant proteins that are necessary for
the light
reactions to occur
hello my name is princess crazel and i
will be showing you today about the
light reaction of photosynthesis
so let's gather our materials we have a
plant
we have water h2o we have
a photosystem this is going to be in
place of photosystem 1 and photosystem 2
and atp synthase and then we have
electrons
this is going to be used as the energy
that is given off by the sun
to power the light reaction then this is
the structure of the
the thylakoid space and these are
um h pluses protons that are going to
create the gradient
all right let's get started so we have
some electrons at rest in a low state of
energy
and then along comes the sunlight and
bam hits them
now when when these rise up to a higher
state of energy
they're able to release energy and they
release energy
and they use that energy as they go
along as they go down the electron
transport chain
they use that energy to um to pump
h protons
into the the space so they're outside
and they're
pumped in
and the calvin cycle has three main
stages the first one
is carbon fixation the second one is
reduction and the third is regeneration
of rubp
so in stage one carbon fixation carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere is fixed
onto a five carbon molecule called rubp
using an enzyme called rubisco
rubisco is a very important enzyme
because it
is the first step it catalyzes the first
step of the entire calvin cycle it
catalyzes
carbon fixation
the breaking of three carbon molecules
five carbon sugar and one co2 molecule
into three carbon sugars
is the most common form in plants
and plants that use this process are
called c3 plants
unfortunately in c3 plants rubisco can
react with oxygen in a process called
photorespiration
this wastes losses of energy and likely
originated when oxygen levels were much
lower
c4 plants don't have this issue instead
of ubisco
the first enzyme is the pep carboxylase
which adds one carbon into a three
common molecule inside the leaf
mesophyll cells
the co2 is released in special bundle
sheath cell
sheath cells and then the molecule
undergoes the calvin cycle
c4 plants are warm season plants that
originated in hot areas
like corn sugarcane and sorghum
well i'm gonna tell you about the live
reactions the first answer couple of
mandatory questions what
they take the is energy from the sun
that warms the earth and use it to get
water releasing
oxygen a system that produces atp
it makes sugar
[Music]
get cold
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was uh one other cabin is i did
not
tell them i did not grade on creativity
so there was no requirement that they
had to be creative they
just had to answer the questions
this shows you that this video segment
allows the students originality
and creativity to come through a lot
more
than they've just given a quiz so
now tropism the premise was
on a zoom call and wherever trophies and
groups
your your friends
noticed things uh um
things uh
whether uh blue planet has either fallen
over
or started or been knocked over or
growing toward the light
so again here's the things that they had
to include
okay all right we'll just go with that
um
so as i mentioned this is the tropism
video
hey what's up oh fantastic on your mind
how does it do that do what
bend towards the light like like how
does it
know how does it know that the light is
coming from that direction
i see what's your opinion on yoga
i mean like it's cool i guess great
bend over like the plant come on
do it what
okay
nice now as you feel your back stretch
let me tell you a little bit about
phototropism
so what exactly is phototropism well it
can best be defined as the response of a
plant
to a unidirectional light source in
positive phototropism
this means the plant will bend towards
the light source
in negative phototropism this means that
the plant will bend
away from the light source in this video
we're going to mainly focus
on positive phototropism
so how does this happen
well the general gist of it is that
the shoot tip which has photoreceptors
perceives the direction of the light
source
and this causes the production of auxin
which will travel down
the shoot and cause cell expansion
in the growing parts of the shoot
now well
the auxin is received by a receptor in
the cell membrane
this then causes the
proton pumps in the cell membrane to
encourage or increase
the pumping of protons out of the
cytoplasm
across the membrane and into the cell
wall what this does
is it acidifies the cell wall this
acidification
triggers expansion enzymes which then
cut the
polysaccharides that hold together the
cellulosic microfibrils of the cell wall
once this cutting has happened the cell
wall
then has greater mobility and is allowed
to expand
so again this is happening on the shaded
side of the stem
so this information could be useful for
many different
aspects of people who want to cultivate
plants because
they should know how to lay out their
crops in a way that
the stems won't run into each other for
example
if a farmer is growing tomatoes they
would want to know that their tomatoes
would grow upward
toward the sky no matter how they orient
them in the first place
as to avoid their stems running into
each other as shown in the picture
even if they oriented the stems downward
they
would still grow upward and so they
wouldn't want a collision of the stems
this information could also be useful
for people who want to conduct further
research about plants
in different conditions involving
gravity such as low to zero gravity
conditions in outer space
knowing the physiology of plants will
help them
have direction in their research
hey guys so you might be wondering why
my plant mango here
is bending towards the sun well it's a
cool thing called phototropism
here we have mango and as you can see
he's bending towards the window in the
light
at the top of mango's stem there is
something called an apical meristem
in his apical meristem he has something
called
photoreceptors which include phototropis
phototropins cryptochrome phytochrome
and some others in agriculture setting
this is
important because if the light is coming
from one direction
it can lead to the plants moving in that
direction and that can lead to crowding
and phototropism is irreversible
so it's important to be aware of how how
the plants will follow the light
and then beyond that it's just cool to
know that
this is how the plants are capturing the
optimal amount of light
at any given time in their lifetime so
yeah there you have it
all right um can people hear me
sure
okay all right i'll leave my video well
i guess i will try to turn on my video
and see if it freezes again then
i'll just turn off okay so
one of the questions we had on the post
quiz is did this video assignment
help you learn the material
and these are some of the testimonials
that the students have put down
just verbatim you know that i helped
them
learn in the light side if they could
watch the videos they would learn the
dark cycle
they they grasp that in order to
understand like in order to explain to
someone you have to understand it
we did have a few people who said that
no they already knew the material they
found the video project to be confusing
so it's not a it's not a silver bullet
but it's something that you could have
in your repertoire
in order to get the students to engage
material differently to bring in their
creativity their individuality which is
an important part of
as we're trying to teach with more
diversion and inclusion
let's but did it help did it improve
their grades
so what we have here is a is a figure
that uh subsequent analysis are produ uh
provided by
dr amy cardase who's on this call so
anything i say incorrectly she can
correct me later on
so on the x-axis we have the pre-scores
that the students
the students got on their quiz
and then on the y-axis we have the post
scores and their quiz
the red line the student falls in the
red line that means
they got the same score on the pre and
post so as you can see
most students have got above the red
line which means
they improve their scores from pre and
post
just by doing the video assignment
and this is visible as well in the
tropisms uh
and and as i've mentioned there for the
tropism
there was no other incentive to study
there was not going to be a final exam
i wrote the questions to be
fairly difficult so they really had to
understand the material in order to do
well on them and i graded all of them
and i uh you know great so as you can
see
there's definitely a benefit to their
grades in addition to the fact that they
themselves
enjoyed doing the assignment
to break this down further we broke it
between the
the two subgroups so in the
photosynthesis
if you were in the photosynthesis
assignment group you did
you improved your scores on the
photosynthesis
sub questions as expected and you did
not
do it and you did not improve it as much
as statistically significant
if you were in the if you are assigned
the dark reactions
which is something we expected because
that they focus on this in light
reactions
and not on the dark reactions and we're
seeing the same kind of pattern
uh for uh for the questions that were
about the dark reactions of
photosynthesis
if that was the subject of your video
you did better on that subject which is
again
what is expected
for tropos it was a little bit different
so for people who did
so for the questions about gravitropism
both
uh gramatropism assignment group and the
phototrophism assignment group improve
their scores
at a significant level one of the
reasons could be
is that because the mechanisms are
somewhat similar
and so this whole idea of signal
transduction this helps them
whether you're doing gravitropism or
phototropism you still have to
understand signal transduction
and so the students were able to
understand that answer the questions
and improve we did not see the same
thing for phototropism
and we'll be digging more into the
specific sub questions
if we can so we can figure out why was
there not the same
level of increase
we also asked the question of how
confident do you feel about the material
we asked that on the pre-quiz
and on the post quiz and as you can see
after you
doing just the video assignment there
was
the students felt more confident
whether it translated into the grades
they're still gaining confidence which
is something that we're trying
stu trying to get students to do because
oftentimes they will see a complex topic
like photosynthesis
or plant reproduction or alternation
generation they're like oh i don't know
this i
i there's no way i can learn this maybe
i shouldn't even be a plant science
major
and so it's important to give them tools
to feel confident about themselves
and to do better on their assignments
so submit so in conclusion as i
mentioned i think video assignments can
be a useful tool for student learning
students really enjoy doing them and
when students enjoy doing they're more
likely to put in more work
and they're more likely to retain it
we're still we're still working on
trying to show the data about retention
and hopefully that will be the subject
of
subsequent presentations
and the instructors can use some of that
assignments to replace lectures
you can have them make a video about
photosynthesis and then you don't have
to spend as much time going over it
and then provide those videos for the
other students to learn
and students are more likely to engage
with the material if it's
something a little more catchy something
different than than just the straight
lecture
so the the we use these videos for a
very specific look
what it you know what is the light
reaction what is the dark reactions
but right now in uh 1101 for this
semester we're asking them to design a
farm
as part of their video assignment and so
you can use that to bring
different kinds together and allow the
students to synthesize material and
actually apply it
as opposed to having to just put that
out on an exam
especially now with exams having to be a
lot of them having to be online
so as i mentioned 1101 we're doing
another assign another video assignment
where the students are designing
a farm they get to pick up which plans
to grow depending on the climate
they picked whether it's tropical and
mediterranean
and then in 2410 margaret uh margaret
frank's class
we're going to be doing a video
settlement focused on alteration of
generations and plant reproduction
last year when we asked the students
what topic they most struggled with in
the first exam that was a topic
and so we're hoping that by using the
video assignment they'll gain a better
understanding of that
and in the spring i'll also be working
with dr tom silva on
activities to try to improve student
scientific writing so
maybe next next year that will be my
next court seminar
and so before i finish up and open it up
for questions
i really have to thank dr miller and dr
silva
without them none of this project could
be done there
they run their courses and they were
really willing to work with me
to put this project into fruition my
collaborators
katherine heffern in microbiology and
amy kardas who's done
a lot of the figures analysis work
marvin pritz who
basically supported me in any ideas that
i might have had has been a phenomenal
advisor
carolyn aslan who is one of the head of
ally and has been great just about
providing directions and really steering
this whole ship through all the zoom
land
covid uh lisa and flyanna who's worked
with me i'm copising the class and doing
something else as well
craig kramer who's edited all the videos
so if you have any video editing
questions please go to craig he's
phenomenal
uh leah cook and working with all the 11
10 classes
and providing any of the backgrounds i
might have had in the last
year and really the the thanks goes to
all the students at steps who
contributed these videos
and the research i i did not make them
this was all our students with just a
minimum amount of prompt
and so with that um thank you very much
and i'm here to take any and all
questions
this is where you do the zoom applause
of yay
questions for anna
and i have not so much a question as an
observation which is you mentioned
that by making these videos
it not only improves the students com
comprehension of concepts but also their
confidence and i could see how that
increased confidence would then transfer
to their mastery of other subjects that
is
go beyond the individual course
yeah it could definitely do because then
they feel more confident
oh i understood this complex topic so i
surely can figure out how to understand
the other one
so they gain the skills on how to break
things down
we're actually asking them a similar
question about that
in the current video project 1101 of
if they had to teach a material how
would they go about doing that we're
hoping to see
that after they've done it that they're
able to articulate better and how would
they set up their lecture
so i totally agree with that
and not a question but a comment and i
it was
it was very interesting to see the um
oh sorry go ahead oh i put a question in
a chat
um i was asking about the time limit i'm
gonna stop
uh it's breaking up again so the
question is
yeah so the question was were the
students given a time limit for the
videos
seems like it would be go long what do
you think is ideal timeline for such
videos
the students were given either four to
six minutes i think for the spring and
three to five for the fall
i very much agree that you can go too
and so i i do think under 10 minutes
um it depends on how topic it is i i
found that three to five four to six
minutes works just fine
uh if you want to make it a group
project you would go longer but
really i think three to five minutes
is an ideal time and
hopefully won't stress these students
okay
um what what i was going to say is not a
question but but again a comment
um it was really interesting to see the
the wide divergence of
styles of videos that these students put
together
um we we saw the singing we there there
are various uh
whiteboard approaches there's post-it
notes i i remember one that there
uh one of the students ran in and sort
of jumped in the frame of the camera and
and was just so wildly enthusiastic
about the dark reactions it was kind of
kind of creepy in some ways but uh uh no
actually it was very it was very good
and and
uh and and the i think when they
understand that
the production value per se is not what
is important
that takes some of the pressure off
right i mean it has students who just
narrate the powerpoint you know i had
students who just who did an audio uh
transcript they wrote up as um
a basic script of what they would say
and so my goal was to make it as
not stressful and really i stress that
like for the tropisms that yes you
should try to put some creativity
in i was not going to judge them
on how many pixels you know they were
going to have or whether their video
froze at some point or speaking of
freezing video
and there is a question from connor lane
so uh
conor had a question
uh he feels that uh connor feels that
the assignments were i've learned the
most with something
have i tried comparing the increase in t
test scores to what happens when you
assign
more traditional assignments
i have not because we have not had the
data for that
um since i just started but that would
be interesting
uh that would definitely be in it if we
can find courses where they do cover
either photoset synthesis
or tropisms we might be able to actually
do it in bills classes synthesis
and so we could give them a same kind of
quiz
since they got the lecture from bill and
that we can include that as we give them
so that thanks for the question it'd be
great um
a question from chase once the students
have ownership of the concept
are there ways to involve them further
in the course
for example submitting a quiz test
question their topic to be as an
assessment
uh that's a great question i've actually
thought of doing that to do that yet but
when i do it either in bill's class or
in the spring
i found that students
i have i have done it where i've asked
you to submit questions with an
incentive that
they will if they're decent questions
i'll use them on the exam
and so i think the students really do
enjoy that and
so i will definitely look forward to
trying that yeah i've enjoyed doing that
in the past too i just
never paired with them having already
taught that concept so it feels like
there should be some good synergy there
it's awesome yeah
yeah i think so that's a that's a great
point let's see if we can
follow it up with some of the students
who are who made the videos befo
any other questions
yeah i have a question hi anna thank you
so much for this great talk
i was actually in bill miller's 1101
class last year so i remember this video
project fondly
yes it is jonah he wrote too
i'm wondering how you know you would
adapt this kind of video concept going
forward to
as you had said in further research
trying to improve scientific writing
and whether that would be a video
project or or how you plan to approach
something like that
so for scientific writing we're not
using the video project a little bit to
see if we can incorporate that as part
of the communication portion
but what we're going to be doing in tom
silva's class
is we're going to have the student for
labs have working
in groups basically submit lab reports
but
first they have to make a figure for the
next lab they get to make a figure and
write the results in discussion
and then eventually retroduction and
then the full paper and so this
incremental approach i've seen done when
i taught at st
john's fisher and that really helps the
students
see how the scientific paper structured
and some of the pitfalls
the the plan is to at the beginning is
to have them
critique a scientific paper and then
compare that
to the critique of sending paper after
getting the training
but i'm wondering if there's a way of
actually incorporating the video project
thanks
for the idea and so jonah do you enjoy
did you enjoy the video project
i enjoyed it to an extent once once i
did it the first time
i tried to go in one take and then when
that didn't end up working
uh i did probably five or ten more takes
to be able to to hammer it down and so
there was like a you know a point of
limiting returns
if that makes sense yeah and i actually
really enjoyed yours it was just we
already had one more what oh we already
had a whiteboard person like in a
chalkboard person that's why didn't
include yours uh it was it was
definitely on the
long list of videos that i first picked
thank you i'm not offended no problem no
i i hope you weren't i'm just like i i
actually remember your videos because i
watched every single one of them
a quick question and i was trying to
remember which implementation was
in person during in-person instruction
and which was during remote instruction
and if you see any trade-offs
so photosynthesis was in person uh
and tropisms was remote
i didn't see any really difference
mine it might be that because people
were so overwhelmed with everything that
there was less
you know people were not making trophies
and videos as creative and as far as i
know no one wrote a song
um but i didn't see you know p
like i otherwise i didn't really see the
any differences
between remote uh everyone
did the assignment so and they seem to
also use props
so i didn't really see any difference i
didn't know if there was a way that we
can measure that
well if there are no more questions i
want to thank
anna for a fascinating seminar
and for pointing out the ways that
we can we instructors can make our
courses
more engaging so thank you anna
thank you very much for giving this
opportunity and again message
me you know send me an email we can set
up ideas um
willing to you know i want to help all
of sips to get
you know put their class make their
classes more engaging
even though they already are
all right see you next week all right
thanks anna
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu